[Musique]
nous sommes le vendredi 26 octobre
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 l'hebdo / tv 60,18 voici les titres
c'est midi c'est le nom de la nouvelle
structure créée par le conseil
départemental et sodexo elle va gérer
114 collège des yvelines avec pour
objectif le fait maison et le
développement des filières locales le
maire de saint cyr l'école évoque un
climat sécuritaire dégradée il lance un
appel auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
bernard daubin demande au gouvernement
de faire régner l'ordre public il nous
expliquera pourquoi dans quelques
instants sur ce plateau et puis comme
chaque vendredi le point sur l'actualité
de la semaine de la précampagne
électorale à coignières à la semaine de
la parentalité pour clayes-sous-bois
bernard de bain bonjour et bienvenue
vous même les républicains de
saint-cyr-l'ecole vous allez nous
accompagner tout au long de cette
édition et nous allons voir avec vous
les raisons de votre lettre au ministre
de l'intérieur mais pour le moment que
va changer la mise en place d'une
nouvelle structure pour la gestion de la
restauration et du nettoyage des
collèges yvelinois sodexo et le
département sont maintenant liés
jusqu'en 2026 explications sodexo et le
département des yvelines viennent
d'officialiser la naissance de ces midi
actionnaires publics et actionnaires
privés réunis au sein d'une structure
qui au 1er janvier 2019 prendra en
charge 114 collège
c'est un très gros un marché pour nous
et c'est une excellente nouvelle pour
sodexo éducation puisque effectivement
le marché de marseille c'est à peu près
320 écoles avec plus de cinquante mille
repas produits chaque jour
et là nous sommes sur 48 mille repas
sont produits chaque jour pour le
département cette structure permettra de
favoriser l'utilisation de produits
locaux et bio 125 producteurs
franciliens seront ainsi sollicité à
mais aussi d'harmoniser l'organisation
de la demi pension avec une plus grande
équité dont le coût des repas pour les
familles actuellement il ya 74 tarifs
différents pour les 116 collège
désormais il y aura des tarifs iront de
1 euro à 4 euros en fonction des revenus
de la famille et le coût du repas est de
oh c'est à dire que le département
continuera à subventionner de 50% à 90%
selon les revenus des familles le prix
du repas dans le cadre de cette
structure des contrats aidés seront
aussi développés et 70 postes de
responsable d'exploitation créé un
montant de ce contrat entre sodexo et
les yvelines et 400 millions d'euros
pour sept ans je vous fais part de mon
profond désarroi face à la dégradation
du climat de sécurité dans ma ville
c'est ainsi que bernard demain maire de
saint cyr l'école et que vous débutez
votre lettre adressée au nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur vous êtes
désespéré aujourd'hui désespérés non
parce que je pense qu'il ya toujours des
solutions hexion d'été désespérée on
baisserait les bras on ne baisse pas les
bras du tout simplement je constate que
depuis quelques temps il ya un certain
nombre d'événements et de
particulièrement d'affrontements et de
bagarres entre bandes qui se produisent
et dont certaines bandes ne sont pas
dites ou issus de la ville mais il ya
des rivalités anciennes et saint cyr
ayant une gare qui mène à la fois vers
dreux et vers rambouillet certainement
se donnent rendez-vous à saisir ce que
pas forcément le bon endroit
c'est une situation inédite comment vous
expliquer cette montée de la violence
vous l'avez constaté au fur et à mesure
des années alors on a eu des épisodes
mais ce qui est important surtout c'est
l'escaladé de la violence
là où vous aviez avant des points et des
bâtons maintenant ça arrive les barres
de fer arrivent les battes de base-ball
parmi les cinq jeunes qui ont été
déférés au tribunal
il y en a une vingtaine qui sont partis
au poste de police cinq ont été déférés
au tribunal dernièrement pour deux
bagarres à deux jours consécutifs
il y avait une baïonnette
je pense pas que c'est pour faire des
caresses il y avait naturellement barres
de fer batte de baseball le marteau
quand on donne un coup de marteau sur un
crâne je pense que ou une baïonnette
certains ne se rendent pas compte
jusqu'où peuvent aller leur leurs actes
en plus ce sont des mineurs de plus en
plus jeunes et ces affrontements de
bandes les jeunes qui s'y retrouvent
je pense que certains ne savent pas
pourquoi ils y sont ils y sont parce
qu'on leur a dit de venir
et là je dirais que le phénomène qui
existe depuis quelques années s'est
amplifiée à cause des réseaux sociaux et
des téléphones portables avant pour
aller téléphoner chez les copains pour
leur dire de venir
c'était plus difficile aujourd'hui en
pleine forme en sont ce film aussi pour
le mettre en ligne et suscité les
réactions aujourd'hui en quelques
secondes on peut mobiliser beaucoup de
monde
les faits dont vous parlez sont survenus
il ya quelques jours
saint cyr l'école devant les têtes
devant un établissement scolaire devant
l'établissement scolaire lycée
professionnel et ensuite le lendemain
dans le prêt du marché un peu plus loin
il y a eu en plus de la police locale la
bac qui de versailles mais surtout de la
suite des renseignements que les
policiers avaient eu les gendarmes à
cheval sont dus faut dire que les
gendarmes à cheval ça impressionne donc
que semer
dire que on ne peut pas avoir tout le
temps d une présence policière comme ça
il faut prendre le problème à la source
des mesures sont attendues dans les
prochaines heures prochains jours de la
part du gouvernement justement parce que
ce fait ces faits ne sont pas isolés sur
la commune de saint cyr l'école on a pu
le constater dans l'actualité nationale
ne serait ce qu'avec ce ce jeune par
exemple qui a braqué l'un de ses
enseignants
aujourd'hui on est plus dans la simple
incivilités vraiment face à des
violences le problème de fond ça reste
coi l'éducation vous attendez quoi comme
mesures concrètes pour vous aider à
reprendre un peu la main sur sur la
sécurité dans votre commune alors ce que
je veux si vous voulez c'est qu'une
commune qui est calme ne bascule pas
dans la violence
mais pour ça on ne peut pas simplement
dire que l'on va s'occuper des communes
qui sont en zone d'éducation prioritaire
par exemple ne faut pas que les autres
atteignent ce niveau de violence nous
avions il ya quelques années nous étions
trois quartiers de la ville était en
contrat urbain de cohésion sociale ce
qu'on appelle le cucs nous l'avons perdu
il ya quatre ans parce que la moyenne de
richesse de des habitants de ces
quartiers a augmenté de 40 euros
squelettes l'état est revenu
oui mais l'été couperet c'est d'abord
une perte pour la ville à l'époque était
d'un peu plus de 600000 euros mais
surtout ce qui était lié à ça c'est
qu'on avait des éducateurs de rue payé
par le conseil départemental la ville en
payant 20 % et du jour au lendemain
vous n'êtes plus en quartiers cucs donc
vous n'avez plus d'éducateurs de rue et
les éducateurs de rue c'était quand même
une alerte que vous avez adressé un
courrier au nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner et vous
évoquez aussi dans ce courrier des
populations qui ne s'intègrent pas qui
ne s'intègrent plus bas des populations
qui s'intègrent pas parce qu'on ne leur
donne pas les moyens de s'intégrer
juste avant de venir j'avais une demande
domiciliation venant du samu social de
paris donc je dis merci à madame
maire de paris de mettre dans les
départements les gens tombent elles
n'arrivent pas à s'occuper
ces gens sont d'origine albanaise bon
savais pas que l'albanie était une zone
de guerre très bien on accueille ces
gens là ils sont là depuis 2016 la
famille mais il y en ad'autres nous en
avons une trentaine de familles sont
logés dans un hôtel depuis deux ans est
ce que c'est normal qu'on soit l'hôtel
qu'on n'ait pas eu de logement pour être
capable de trouver une autonomie c'est
la première des choses
la deuxième des choses c'est qu'on a des
problèmes dans les écoles y compris des
écoles maternelles depuis deux ans et
que le maternelles écoles élémentaires
parce que ses enfants ont été mis
directement dans le bain scolaire sans
parler un mot de français
parce que l'école qui est capable
d'accueillir ces enfants étrangers à
fontenay le fleury n'a plus de place
donc je demande aux milices d'éducation
nationale mettez les moyens pour qu'on
accueille des réfugiés
vous ne disiez tout à l'heure que vous
n'étiez pas désespérer vous n'avez pas
envie de jeter l'épongé
ah non pas du tout d'abord parce que
c'est pas un beau caractère faut qu'on
trouve les moyens mais c'est pas
uniquement des moyens répressifs je
dirais que si j'avais plus de moyens
j'aurais peut-être plus de police
municipale nous avons fait des efforts
en terme de vidéo surveillance ne serait
ce que nous avons créé avec eux
fontenelle pleurer bois d'arcy un centre
urbain intercommunal de
vidéosurveillance mais ça ne suffit pas
pour moi c'est à la base et l'école est
le premier endroit où on doit pouvoir
éduquer les enfants pour qu'ensuite ils
quittent pas l'école parce qu'ils sont
désoeuvrés qui ne bascule pas dans la
violence est construite et puise par la
formation avoir du travail
bernard dedans vous restez avec nous
maire de saint cyr l'école je rappelle
que vous avez adressé donc ce courrier
au ministre de l'intérieur pour
l'alerter sur la situation vous
rencontrez actuellement à l'insécurité
dans votre commune et ça ne touche pas
uniquement la commune de saint cyr on a
eu l'occasion de le leur rappeler
l'actualité nous allons en faire le tour
à présent dans la suite de cet hebdo
auparavant c'est l'heure de notre
rubrique ça s'est passé
[Musique]
ouais et escale cette semaine en 1993 en
novembre la ville d'elancourt lance la
première réhabilitation pardon du coeur
historique est de saint quentin en
yvelines le quartier 17 mar c'est en
1965 75 que ce quartier a vu le jour
avec une conception aujourd'hui obsolète
[Musique]
vingt ans après les 7 mars font peau
neuve
précurseur ce centre intégré ancien fer
de lance de la vie nouvelle franchi une
autre étape de sa maturité
alors que l'engouement s'est déplacé
vers l'est les sept marc affiche de
nouvelles ambitions urbaine face à un
isolement dont ils font aujourd'hui les
vrais te centre a perdu son attractivité
les gens ne viennent plus il est devenu
triste et il faut donc leur structure et
que nous avons nous avons cherché à
adapter
nous avons vu que c'était tout à fait
insuffisant c'est une véritable
transformation laquelle il faut procéder
en termes d'architecturé cette volonté
de changement entraîne de sérieux
bouleversements les plus importants sont
le déplacement de l'intermarché vers le
rond-point de cette marque qui lui
évitera de l'actuelle station service
située près du commissariat ainsi que de
nouvelles places de parking
autre modification de taille
l'élargissement des boyaux ou des rues
étroites propice aux courants d'air
ainsi que la destruction de passerelles
et l'aménagement des accès souterrain
toutes ces mesures s'accompagnent en de
la construction de nouveaux logements
offriront de nouvelles perspectives tant
sur le plan de l'architecturé que de la
vie on sait maintenant que vu la
présence des hauts champs des
centre-ville de saint-quentin et autres
ce type de 2 200 commercial marche mal
donc il faut qu'ils marchent au louvre
on perd mais du stationnement en
périphérie on on montre tous les
commerces ont fait des passages abriter
citera pour que les rues deviennent
accueillant vivant et dynamique destinée
à redynamiser le centre à la demande des
commerçants qui traverse actuellement
une passe difficile
la restructuration 17 mar n'en reste pas
moins un pari social celui d'améliorer
le cadre de vie des élans courtois pour
l'avenir dans l'immédiat
et avant que cette transformation ne
prenne corps il faudra qu aux termes de
l' enquête publique qui débute le 22
avril prochain la nouvelle zac proposé
par le pea soit acceptée par les
pouvoirs publics
[Musique]
retour en 2018 avec notre invité les
événements marquants de cette semaine
nous débutons par de la politique pierre
bédier dorénavant président des
républicains des yvelines vient de faire
connaître sa feuille de route et la
composition de son nouveau bureau
comme annoncé il a fait preuve
d'ouverture en donnant deux vice
présidence à ses anciens opposants lors
de la campagne
alexandra du blanche est ainsi en charge
du projet et othman menace roux chargé
aide des élections bernard de bain cette
nouvelle organisation de la fédération
vous en êtes satisfait ça fait preuve
d'ouverture pour vous aujourd'hui les
choses se sont apaisées s'apaiser au
sein de ge après passe à l'ouverture
pour moi c'est la famille s'est
rassemblée qui ai eu plusieurs candidats
au contraire c'était formidable parce
que s'il n'y avait qu'un seul candidat
souhaité un petit peu dommage est la
deuxième des choses maintenant faut se
mettre au travail parce que depuis la
les élections présidentielles on peut
pas des n'hésitez pas c'est gratuit
dans le département quelle doit être la
priorité des républicains justement pour
le département des yvelines 20 ans
allait au devant des gens porter leur
parole et leurs besoins
faire des propositions c'est donc se met
au travail parce que ça dort mais un peu
au niveau national tout de même cette
semaine un sondage ipsos nous apprenait
que marion maréchal recueillez plus
d'opinions favorables que laurent
wauquiez auprès des sympathisants des
républicains ça veut dire que les
républicains doivent s'ouvrir se durcir
un peu la ligne à droite
vous savez moi j'ai adhéré au rpr il ya
quelques années parce que j'ai toujours
une fibre gaulliste dans l'action du
général de gaulle y avait un volet
social qui était très important
lorsqu'il y avait des rassemblements il
y avait une base qui venait
véritablement pop qui était
véritablement populaire ça je pense que
c'est indispensable
et puis il ya certains discours et
certaines attitudes
que je ne pourrais pas accepté donc pour
moi il est important de retrouver cet
élan que nous avions il ya quelques
années
parlons à présent d'une autre formation
politique la france
insoumis jean luc mélenchon persiste et
signe après son coup de colère la
semaine dernière il est toujours agacé
énervé contre la justice le gouvernement
est la presse nous recevions cette
semaine des responsables du groupe
d'action de la france soumise à trappes
ecoutez-le il ya des militants qui
effectivement se pose des questions il
va un peu loin et ses avants
mais quand on connaît nous on connaît
jean luc mélenchon depuis quelques
années on le suit on connaît sa capacité
à s'indigner avec avec tempérament et
c'est donc si vous voulez nous on n'est
pas choqué de ça ce qui nous choque
davantage c'est toute la machine
judiciaire et médiatique qui s'est mise
en oeuvre à cette occasion là pour des
faits des faits pour l'instant ne sont
pas prouvés qu'ils sont pas démontrés
bernard de dans cette réaction de
jean-luc mélenchon vous assomme vous a
choqué pardon de la part de quelqu'un
qui aspire à être président de la
république
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un manque de
maîtrise maintenant sur le fond de la
faire vous savez quand on a vu aussi la
déferlante pendant la campagne contre
françois fillon
dix-huit mois après on attend encore
moi je n'ai rien à dire sur les
accusations ou des interrogations
concernant la campagne de monsieur
mélenchon est ce que l'état cherche tout
de même à déstabiliser l'opposition
c'est en tout cas ce qu'avance la france
est soumise
je pense qu'il ya des juges aussi il
faut on est quand même dans un état de
droit donc je pense que la première des
choses c'est fair eu confiance en la
justice
dernier sujet politique sur le thème
lesquels j'aimerais vous faire réagir
avant de vous libérer pour 7,8 hebdo qui
va se continuer ensuite elle c'est
l'élection qui se prépare à coignières
après la démission du maire mise à mal
par une partie de son opposition une
nouvelle élection aura lieu le 25
novembre déjà 4 litres sont connus dont
2 de l'ancienne majorité
est-ce que vous avez échangé par exemple
avec le maire de quoi niasse que vous
avez regardé ce qui s'y passe et je vous
pose aussi cette question parce que vous
avez connu des rapports difficiles au
sein de la majorité avec l'opposition
aussi dans la commune de saint cyr
l'école ce n'est jamais un moment très
agréable pour un élu oui
une mandature qui n'a pas été facile
tous les jours
contrairement à celle celle qui est
actuel écoutez moi je suis pas du tout
au courant des problèmes j'ai dû
naturellement dans la presse les raisons
aussi qui ont poussé cette démission
pense que les électeurs de poignard
jugeront le même merci bernard de bain
de nous avoir accompagnés pendant une
bonne partie de cette édition maire de
saint cyr je rappelle pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent et que vous demander à l'état
d'intervenir pour faire régner l'ordre
public notamment dans votre commune
merci à vous à nous pour suivre
excessivement avec la semaine de la
parentalité qui vient de se tenir aux
clayes-sous-bois cette occasion des
ateliers d'initiation avec des massages
pour les bébés étaient notamment proposé
le reportage de manou varaldo des bébés
plus détendu grâce à des massages
bien-être
durant une heure et quart auxiliaire de
puériculture et éducatrice pour jeunes
enfants ont expliqué les bons gestes aux
parents pour les apaiser
chaque massage a sa petite histoire un
papillon qui se posent sur la jambe et
qui s'envole pour arriver à ses pieds
des histoires qui participent à la
détente du bébé et qui permettent aux
parents de mieux retenir les gestes dans
la façon parfait
le papillon faire des massages du pied à
votre enfant à l'aide de votre pouce
exercé de légères pressions sur les bras
et des petites frictions sur les jambes
ou encore massage de la tête tant de
techniques donné que reproduisent les
mamans pendant ce moment de douceur des
hormones de plaisir sont sécrétées ce
qui procure une sensation de détente au
bébé et stimule le développement
sensoriel
mais avant chaque massage les mamans
sont invités à appliquer de l'huile sur
leurs mains pour la faire chauffer et à
tout un protocole pour masser un enfant
ont fait par partie en général c'est à
dire on commence par les jambes les bras
pour bien là c'est un enfant faut rester
dans un endroit agréable avec une
température assez élevée de 23 degrés et
il faut effectuer des pressions assez
douces un peu comme quand on va se faire
masser et lors du massage une relation
privilégiée secret entre l'enfant et le
parent contrôleurs agents de terre un
conducteur le personnel de la société
sqy bus a suivi jeudi une journée
d'information sur la sécurité
une journée pour rappeler quelques
règles fondamentales comme le respect
des distances mais aussi prévenir les
addictions ou encore hey simuler des
situations à d'accidents mélanie poker
et si les sourires sont toujours là
c'est que ce bus qui bascule est un
outil pédagogique
un des ateliers d'une journée de
sensibilisation ski bus et cars périer
c'est à la fois prendre conscience des
risques de la portée du risque en les
mettant en fonction des différents
ateliers en situation d'accident donc
avec des simulations des chocs à des
vitesses des tonneaux un car scolaire
qui se couche mais également se
permettre de se connaître soi même une
quarantaine de partenaires a été
sollicité pour cette deuxième édition
pompiers médecine du travail ou encore
l'association
le port de la ceinture on la met
systématiquement ses rentrées dans notre
culture
le port de la ceinture tout le monde
même bébé ils savent à y mettre la
ceinture mais il la met mal pour la mais
par peur du gendarme par réflexe mais on
la met mal ils saisissent pas que ça
doit être ça doit pas être dans les
partis moi il sait pas qu on doit
enlever les doudous l'île soeur raconte
enlever le téléphone portable de la
proche ski bus et les cars périer c'est
lary 220 conducteur qui assurent 70
service par jour
comme françoise qui transportent des
élèves depuis trois ans
14h30 quotidienne derrière un volant je
me lance le test
aulaqi opticienne va vous les
interpréter la station déjà de quitter
sa place d'un patient de se comporter
sur la route il ya des petites choses
comme ça car on se rend compte une
journée dédiée aux conducteurs de bus
mais aussi les autres salariés
74 % des accidents mortels ont lieu lors
de trajets quotidiens
il était une figure de l'église
orthodoxe en france l'archimandrite
barsanuphe est décédé le 20 octobre
dernier à 83 ans
la vice président de la confédération
mondiale des religions pour la paix il
était aussi higoumène du script du
saint-esprit au mesnil saint denis connu
notamment pour ses engagements au
service du dialogue interreligieux et
laura impulser la construction d'une
dizaine d'églises orthodoxes en france
ces funérailles ont eu lieu cette
semaine à la cathédrale orthodoxe de la
sainte trinité à paris
[Musique]
chaque vendredi nous jetons aussi un
coup d'oeil sur le reste de l'actualité
en ile-de-france avec nos confrères de
via grand paris et aujourd'hui c'est à
elles vivent que nous nous rendrons la
ville participent à l'opération octobre
rose une campagne de lutte contre le
cancer du sein
à l'occasion d'octobre rose mois de
mobilisation contre le cancer du sein
l'ap-hp l'entreprise pharmaceutique
roche organise des ateliers d'auto
palpation comme ici à l'hôpital paul
brousse de villejuif à l'aide d'un buste
en silicone des infirmières sensibilise
les femmes aux signes qui doivent les
alerter
la différence entre les celui là est la
peau d'orange et le cartonnage c'est
vous touchez là oui c'est tout
c'est une présence anormale qui a fait
que vous devez consulter votre médecin
cette action de prévention doit
permettre aux femmes de détecter les
possibles anomalies sur leurs poitrines
des gestes fondamentaux pour traiter au
plus vite impossible cancer du sein
c'est vraiment de la sensibilisation 1
donc c'est à dire que le buste est au
plus proche de ce qu'on peut faire
par rapport à ce qu'elle pourrait
éventuellement ressentir mais c'est
vraiment leur dire voilà
prenez l'habitude de vous regarder
prenez l'habitude de vous palpez de
connaître votre corps soyez capables si
quelque chose n'est pas comme d'habitude
de venir voir le médecin très tôt et de
dire voilà ça d'habitude je le sens pas
où ça d'habitude je ne le vois pas en
france le cancer du sein touche près
d'une femme sur neuf c'est la fin de cet
hebdo le journal revient lundi avec
grégory canal et à 18h en direct
n'oubliez pas ce durant la nuit de
samedi à dimanche de reculer vos montres
vos horloges à vos réveils d'une heure
puisque nous passerons à l'heure est
divers excellent week end
[Musique]